[Musique]
bienvenue dans encore vous l'émission
qui invite des personnages que vous
savez forcément déjà vu au ciné ou à la
télé avec aujourd'hui une vedette de la
musique une grande légende jour
attendait parce qu'on me parle dans le
commensal annuler abri mais là on est en
direct on est un peu en carafe et bahia
personne d'autre quoi la serveuse d'un
café d'en bas mais on a très bien fait
la montée mais finalement je reçois à la
serveuse qui remplace la chanteuse au
dernier moment et deviennent star
[Musique]
à
masseube on va peut-être pas quelqu'un
d'autre du coup
très bien je perds on va passer à
l'union d'avoir ou non en tant que je
n'aurai qu'une seule chance alors je
vais là producteurs d'asie en quête de
renouveau oui toi qui m'a dit tu
cherchais un diamant brut au coeur pur
cas de la musique dans l'âme écoute
plutôt ça
c'est fait ce qui m'anime jossinet aussi
vous permettez on va revenir sur ce
début de carrière impressionnante qui a
commencé il ya maintenant quoi 20
secondes quand vous regardez se passer
tout va très vite quand on est une
petite serveuse qui remplace la
chanteuse au dernier moment et devient
une star mais aujourd'hui même si j'ai
une grande villa et que je suis habillé
uniquement par des créateurs je serai
toujours cette petite serveuse au fond
mais en star moi je l'avais senti que
vous avez le truc non parce que vous
êtes dans votre manière de dire je vous
sers autre chose faire autre chose
[Musique]
il suffit de croire c'est pas trop lourd
à porter cette célébrité je vous cache
pas contre les tournages les tournées
les dîners les dix nage ma vie de star
et bien solitaire même si le succès m'a
permis de renouer avec mon père qui m'a
abandonnée quand j'étais petit
ça fait maintenant quelques minutes que
vous êtes une star
et qu'est ce que vous dites tous ceux
qui vous critiquent qu'ils jugent votre
dernier album trop commercial je
rappelle quand même car duo avec sting
steam c'est une idée de nouveaux
producteurs managers qui est aussi mon
père et puis vous savez comme disait
maria callas il vaut mieux être une
bonne chanteuse populaire qu'une
mauvaise en plus
nourris chanteuse d'opéra ça va deux
incidents alors on va pas se mentir
certains considèrent que vous êtes déjà
has been on vous dit fatigué accro aux
médicaments alcoolique même ça vous fait
souffrir vous savez a réalisé un plus au
club
serveuse qui a remplacé la chanteuse au
dernier moment et qui est devenu une
star tu es parti au mauvais moment mais
tu resteras pour nous irremplaçable
salut l'artiste
attendait son producteur de permanence
que vous pouvez d'ores et déjà retrouver
tous ses plus grands succès dans un
coffret collector quelle star
[Musique]
je serais vous étiez morte ah non moi je
suis la jumelle jalouse du succès de sa
soeur à et vous chantez pas du tout mais
je suis très méchante